- [Narrator] Can flexible classrooms
actually boost student achievement?
Will this comfortable chair
and this emoji pillow
improve academic performance?
Well, no.
It's not the furniture,
but a study out of England
looked at 27 schools, 153 classrooms,
and 3,766 students across the country
and concluded that flexible
welcoming classrooms
did raise test scores.
In fact, classroom flexibility
is about as important
as air quality, light, or temperature
in boosting academic outcomes.
And taken together, flexibility
and a student's sense
of ownership account for over a quarter
of the academic benefit
attributed to classroom design.
So what's happening?
It turns out that flexible classrooms
change teaching and learning habits.
They are versatile, so they
support a broader range
of educational strategies
and they're modifiable too.
So they can quickly be adapted
to meet individual and group needs.
That makes a big difference,
because the research shows
that using a mix of strategies
to teach a lesson, direct instruction,
group work, independent inquiry,
drives deeper learning among students.
So changing the furniture
in your classroom
will almost certainly
have no impact at all.
If you don't change your teaching too.
To learn more about the research
on classroom design and flexible spaces,
look for the link
displayed with this post,
or search for the phrase
flexible classroom
research on edutopia.org.